solve the system of equations using any
method so we have y
is equal to two times the quantity x
minus four squared plus three we also
have y is equal to negative x squared
plus two x minus two so the solution or
if it might be one or might be none it
might be multi two solutions but the
solutions to this quadrat to this system
occur
for the x values that generate the same
y values so the same x and y that
satisfy both of these equations so in
order to find the x values they need to
equal the same y value so this y has to
be that y value so the solution is going
to occur when this guy right here
negative x squared plus 2 x
minus 2 is equal to
is equal to that guy up there
is equal to two times x minus four
squared
plus three and now let's just try to
solve for x so the left-hand side not a
lot well let's let's just well we're
going to have to multiply this out so
let's do that first it's negative x
squared plus 2x minus 2 is equal to and
on the right hand side 2 times x minus 4
squared is x squared minus 8x plus
plus 3 this is going to be equal to 2 x
squared i'm just distributing the 2
minus 16x 2x squared minus 16x plus 32
plus 3
which is equal to
this is equal to 2 x squared minus 16 x
plus 35
and that's of course going to be equal
to the thing on the left hand side
negative x squared plus two x
minus two
and now let's well let's just let's just
subtr let's
let's just get rid of this whole thing
from the left hand side all at once
by
adding x squared to both sides we could
all do it in one step we're going to add
x squared to both sides let's subtract
2x from both sides let's subtract 2x
from both sides and let's add 2 to both
sides
and let's add 2 to both sides and we
will get
on the left hand side those cancel out
those cancel out those cancel out you're
left with 0 is equal to 2x squared plus
x squared is
3 x squared negative 16x minus 2x is
negative 18 x
and then 35 plus 2 is 37 plus 37 so we
just have a plain vanilla quadratic
equation right here and we might as well
apply the quadratic formula here to try
to solve it so our solutions are going
to be x is equal to negative b
well b is negative 18 so negative b is
positive 18. so it's 18 plus or minus
the square root
of 18 squared
18 squared minus
times 3
times c times 37
all of that
over 2 times a 2 times 3 which is 6. now
let's think about what this is going to
be
over here we have so it's 18 plus or
minus the square root of well let's just
use our calculator i can multiply it out
but i think so if 18 squared
18 squared minus
4 times 3 times 37
negative 120 so 18 plus or minus square
root of negative
and you might have even be able to
figure out this is negative 4 times 3 is
12 12 times 37 is
going to be a bigger number than 18
although it's you know it's not 100
obvious but you might be able to just
get the intuition there but we
definitely end up with a negative number
under the radical here
now for dealing with real numbers there
is no
square root of negative 120. so there is
no solution to this quadratic equation
there is no
solution
and if we wanted to we could have just
looked at the discriminant the
discriminant is this part b squared
minus 4ac we see the discriminant is
negative there's no solution which means
that these two guys these two equations
never intersect there is no
solution
to
the system
there are no x values that when you put
into both of these equations give you
the exact same y value now let's think a
little bit about why that happened
this one is already in kind of our
y-intercept form and it's an upward
opening parabola so it looks something
like this i'll do my best to draw it
just a quick and dirty version of it let
me draw my axes in a in a neutral color
so let's say that this right here
is my y-axis that right there is my
x-axis x and y
this vertex it's in the vertex form
occurs when x is equal to 4 and y is
equal to 3 so x is equal to 4 and y is
equal to 3 and it's an upward opening
parabola we have a positive coefficient
out here so this will look something
like this
it will look something like this
i don't know the exact thing but look
that's close enough now what will this
thing look like well it's a downward
opening parabola and we can actually put
this in vertex form let me do that let
me do that let me put the second
equation in vertex form just so we have
it so we have a good sense so y is equal
to we could factor out a negative one
negative
x squared minus two x
plus two
x squared minus two x plus two and
actually let me put the plus two further
out
plus
two
all the way up out there and then we
could say okay half of negative two is
negative one you square it so you have a
plus one and then a minus one there and
then this part right over here we can
rewrite as x minus 1 squared so it
becomes
negative
x minus 1 squared
let me just do it one step at a time i
don't want to skip steps negative x
minus 1 squared minus 1 plus 2. so
that's plus 1 out here
or if we want to distribute the negative
we get
y is equal to negative x minus 1 squared
minus 1. so here the vertex occurs at x
is equal to 1 y is equal to negative 1.
x is equal to 1
y is equal to negative 1. the vertex is
there and this is a downward opening
parabola we have a negative coefficient
out here on the on the second degree
term so it's going to look something
like this it's going to look something
like
this
so as you see they don't intersect this
is this vertex is above it and it opens
upward this is its minimum point and
it's above this guy's maximum point so
they will never intersect so there is no
solution to this system of equations